Hey everyone, I'm Surim. I'm the CEO and
co-founder of Starling Search and today
my talk
is a signal's die after retrieval
boundary. So, we'll look into
uh what are agents essentially, why
agents fail, what is uh the cause of
fails in retrieval particularly, and how
to make actually signals cross the
retrieval boundary, and how to make your
agent basically outcome fair.
So, uh let's get started.
What is an agent? An agent is an LLM
that has agency to reason, invoke tools,
uh interact with the real world,
retrieve
uh the memory to complete the task. One
major loop here is missing is uh
learning. It should also learn from what
worked and what didn't work. Suppose uh
if I had to uh
explain what is agent, I I can explain
with react agent.
So, if I had to explain uh what agent
does, I would explain with react agent.
So, basically use it from the agent
and execute it in a loop, uh client to
retrieval search, and then pause when
the task is complete. This is very basic
react architecture. One thing that is
missing is how to make agent learn from
the outcome.
So, agent keeps failing at the same
task. Gartner reported 85% of AI just
failing traction. So, it's in McKinsey's
2025 report.
The problem came out to be
most of the time is that retrieval is
static. 73% of our uh pipelines fails
because of retrieval, not generation,
and context stuffing.
So, a recent
uh post from Ram Sriram, the ex-CTO of
Pinecone, said,
"Uh we have been optimizing for the
wrong thing. You are paying a lot for
your agent's memory. This is probably
broken, and we have been optimizing for
the wrong things. We made wrong answers
appear faster and cheaper, but we forgot
to make retrieval learn."
So, why does this does does does it
matter?
Again, uh, the third problem is agents
are not outcome-informed.
So, there's a missing layer between
evals and action. Your observability has
all the traces,
uh, all the stack that capture
observability is the stack that capture
every tool call, every LM completion,
every exceptions. Your eval suite judges
whether the final output was correct or
wrong, basically pass or fail.
But, these
evals
are not
reflected in agent, uh, context, skills,
and defines my agent action in any ways.
Right?
So, the agent doesn't have any access to
why yesterday's runs, uh, runs passed or
failed. The eval signal dies in the
dashboard. This is a missing layer, a
system that consume traces, absorb eval,
and convert both into retrieval guidance
for future runs.
So, there's a manual improvement task,
and engineer actually has to sit and see
if the eval and observability perform
well. Rewrite the prompt, redeploy it,
upgrade either and create your expensive
model, restructure to our harness, or
fine-tune the custom models.
Why are current memories failing? Why
memories was designed to actually
address this, but,
uh, uh,
it's not.
So, let's see, uh, a what we have in our
the current system
uh, and current memory is that they
basically store user preferences,
profile, conversation history, or
long-lived personalization.
So, chat experience is not
self-improving learning systems for
production. If you see
the already existing approach in the
market, there's a
LangChain,
there's Mem0, which does extracted past
preferences. The user's retrieval signal
is embedding similarity.
Does it learn from outcome? No.
Uh
so, we have come up with something
called utility score, which is a
similarity weighted by how useful it is
for the agent to execute the task. It
has actually the history of past pieces
and past outcomes.
So, we came up with Agent RX, and that
is agent's the runtime experience. It's
a runtime
layer that let the large language agent
improve from experiences without
retraining, fine-tuning, or manual
prompt engineering.
How it's a little different from compile
time like DS5 because of you bake in all
the lessons in the prompt, here is
actually improving
while it is executing the task.
So,
which again introduces utility score.
So, you do not retrieve by keyword, you
do retrieve by semantic similarity to
the current task weighted by whether
those memories have historically helped
or hurt
the execution or the outcome. The event
outcome becomes a first-class signal in
the retrieval re-ranking and not just
for retrieval.
One of the
key things is
it treat memory as reasoning,
not as facts, statistics, fact
with no context and no history, but
reasoning. Like suppose if if there's a
if there is a customer support bot
looking for a refund, you will not
really say, "Hey, user prefers uh uh
dark theme or user prefers
to be called by a shorter name." It's
actually reason about query like
if some someone asked for refund, you
should check the settlement before
refunding it so that the the the
customer doesn't get paid refund twice.
So, we act based on usefulness. Context
is updated based on task. So, this is a
very big thing
because most of the agents deal with
context stuffing and this has been
brought up in the past and learn from
history and reasoning, right? Talking
about benchmarks.
So, we have benchmarks
our memory system reflect on towel bench
which essentially measure if agents have
followed a policy well or not.
So, we have seen
the
performance improve from 66 to 76%
without baking in uh skills and with
skills reflect performance at 80. So,
once there are enough memory like 10
memories, uh what we do is we bake in
the
reasoning and the understanding into
skills so that your agent always remains
updated. What happens most of the time
we have seen suppose you have a product
SQL agent and there's a system there's a
column in system prompt. Even though
that column is no useful anymore, it
remains in the system prompt. So,
there's no system right now that can
update that, "Hey, there's no column
uh right now called this. So, maybe
probably you shouldn't entertain it in
the future. And this is possible with
skills that because it is always uses
calls that skill
updated skill all the time.
And the similar behavior has been
seen in GPT-5.4.
Uh, we have also benchmarked it on
agentic task.
Which essentially test a model's ability
to reason, plan, and use tools or
extended multi-step workflows rather
than measuring a static Q&A. So, you can
see here,
uh, when does it was the human last exam
with drug, it get 47.5.
If it is starting from the baseline
35.7.
Uh, with the
other memory system, it gets to 58.2.
But with the refined memory system, uh,
it gets to 61.3%.
So, this this kind of trend is shown in
another, uh, agentic benchmarks, uh, as
well, like Big Code Bench, like Long TV,
etc.
So, of course, there are limitations to
this, uh,
to this approach. First of all, there's
a cold start. So, in the beginning, it's
pure semantic search until,
uh, enough reviews have been
accumulated. Uh,
there's a utility drift. Maybe
sometimes, uh, similar memories could
come up. There are a lot of problems
that could come at scale with this
experience, but we have combat most of
them. Uh, there's a review quality. So,
noisy labels can make the utility noisy
as well. And there is, uh,
hyperparameter called lambda that is
associated with credit and re-ranking.
So, we have built reflect in such a way
that most of these problems and most of
these elements are now reduced except
for cold start which we cannot do much
about it. Uh
let's get into the demo.
So let's check this demo.
Um
So it's a basically a product SQL demo.
I'll give ask it to search some product
in
SQL database and see if it is able to
find it out.
So can you find me a gaming mouse?
Zero memories retrieved. I couldn't find
a gaming mouse. Uh okay. So maybe
let's just go and see what's happening
in the dashboard.
Okay. It came out that
I'm going on another benchmark that with
the agent bench with actions essentially
measures if agent has actually done the
right reasoning, planning, and uh
have followed.
Which essentially test a model's ability
to reason, plan, and use tools over
extended multi-step workflows rather
than measuring a static Q&A. So you can
see here
uh
with the suppose the human last exam
uh with drug you get 47.5.
If it is starting from the baseline
35.7.
Uh with the
other memory system, it gets 258.2 but
with the result memory system, uh it
gets 261.3%.
So, this this kind of trend is shown in
another
uh
adaptive benchmarks
as well like big code bench, my long TV,
etc.
Wait, let's check.
I couldn't find I couldn't find any
gaming mouse in the product catalog.
So, suppose I want to market fail and
sell
it
give any relevant
No.
Because there is a there is a wireless
mouse in the database.
And I have submitted the failure.
Uh
this was the input. This was the
response. I couldn't find any.
And this was a trajectory and tool
quality. So, you can see the product is
empty
with this product or with this query.
Let's uh let's check again what happens
now.
Let's see now now what happens.
Okay, ID uh
So, it searched a wireless mouse.
Uh
Let's see what happens in the dashboard
now.
Finally, a gaming mouse was input. The
response was I found a product related
to mouse as the mouse failed to find any
kind of relevant. Let then, The most
important thing is
how the tool call evolved. You can see
that previously the tool calls
or the trajectory
used to look just with one search, that
is search products it called.
And the product was empty. Now, the
trajectory has changed
in the production and
it found something in the product
and it uh is still calling search
product to call but it is getting some
answer that we fed in as a feedback. So,
uh
that's the demo and
the most important thing that is
happening over here is it's forming
memories which is retrieved based on the
utility score that is the score which
basically keeps improving keeps
re-ranking itself on the basis of how
useful that memory was.
So, uh
You can see from this traces past traces
which memory
uh so this memory scores keep changing
and after certain while after suppose uh
five reviews maybe can bake in these
findings or these new updates in a
skill.
Without
so without changing the existing prompt
you can actually update
certain things that agent
draws
a lot from. So,
uh you can update the skill which is
very cool. So,
uh I hope everything was
I hope
you get to try
this new feature this new
uh runtime experience that we have
built.
You want more details you can visit our
website and
you can also contact me if I have still
my grace@alishascollection.com.
I will reply.
Thank you.